that's our
uh
producer raleigh now he's never even
masturbated in his life which is true
riley the the never masturbated
give it a shot
no no no no you can't he's like it's too
late now no he no it's not too i don't
think it's too late i don't know
hopefully he can i don't know he might
have autism i don't even know him that
well he's a great great guy and i'm glad
that he's here
sorry i didn't mean to bring that up it
just kind of fell in a conversation that
and uh are you doing okay riley i am
there you go you just never masturbated
nope
he's he's part of a religious group and
they don't do it how are what type of
religion
uh christian
oh
i was a catholic and they would talk to
you about coming oh okay oh i had some
priests ask me about you you grew up
catholic right do you uh or no we were
like sixth baptist i think oh okay
do you ever get any guys talking to you
about come
we had a
professor i guess or i think then it was
a teacher you know yeah and he would i
remember he drew a picture
of a wiener
ejaculating
chalkboard and it was he like kind of
described like he told us what the
feelings would be like we wouldn't be
able to handle it and stuff and then he
drew it like um
he drew the
the
yeah the ejaculate just
coming out it was really insane was he
like
was he like making the noise with it i
remember he i do remember it was one of
those double chalkboards here comes a
big one
i remember he would put the marker on
the board and then walk
that's crazy it was pretty crazy man and
he wore the shortest shorts too he died
man willie i think
derek osner was his name or something
and i think his son might have died but
he died but
his son died too i'm pretty sure uh i
don't want to say that but i'm pretty
sure and he had the biggest mustache
like i don't know his words like i felt
like his words big mustache and he was
talking bro his mustache came over both
lips so it was like
the words couldn't even some of the
words you just had to guess what they
were people thought he was
some people thought he was black people
don't know what was going on
we just couldn't understand what he was
talking about it was crazy you know it's
just different times back then
so you don't beat off this is crazy
we're just skimming past it never once
in your life how old are you 23. all
right you got time
you're going to get one off
i promise i promise you're gonna go oh
dude i'll pat him on the back hard
enough you know what i'm saying sorry
brother and i don't want to say that
kind of stuff in front of i you know i'm
not trying to
i'm trying not to jerk off and he
doesn't so it's
you know it's interesting
how many times do you mind if i ask you
about do you have wet dreams a lot
i don't
that's crazy what do you what happens
rally do you
and
yeah i mean but you're saving yourself
first
to talk about this or no no we're fine
i'm not gay about talking about guys
coming
all right
what uh
do you have a lot of sensations in your
body riley
uh not really no
i was kidding you baby
you can't ask about sensations
i'm sorry man
can we even hear riley do we have a mic
we do uh do you have a lot of sensations
in your body rodney
uh not really are you serious man
you have no
feelings
i didn't know this brother
don't you get hurt have you had have you
felt pain
physically pain physical
what kind of physical pain like you ever
break a bone or anything
no you ever get a cut
i've gotten cuts what do you have what
that feels when you get caught
i don't know i put a put a band-aid on
but does anything come does anything
come out yeah
yeah all right but but you're okay
though riley right you don't have like a
that you don't have a birth defect or
something i don't okay
that's what i was concerned with if you
don't have any oh it's like you're
behind us
no no i don't so you get erection right
okay and what do you do when you do do
you go outside do you put your hands in
like a
do you just calm down
i just ignore it dang wow that is power
bro it's pretty impressive that's power
dude you're like the carl malone of your
own yeah bro i mean that isn't just
train baby
yeah wow i mean
that's wild man yeah and i i
yeah i don't want to see i just want you
to be i want you to be happy man
do you wish you never had
never had come
no yeah ejaculated there's never one
part of me that wants that yeah having
never i mean it'd be fun to experience
it again for the first time yeah that
would be nice but no i'm proud i'm proud
of almost every one of them
almost across the board but
nice we did it
oh so you're in four eight there's been
a couple years
i don't have any problem with it
some of my boys are like you're trying
not to jerk off yeah i try i feel bad
when i do for some reason it makes me
feel i just feel disheartened it just
goes away right away wow like i don't
feel
my friends feel that way my friend matt
who i do my podcast with he's a big like
it's pigging out don't be gross don't
jerk off like that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one